my name is Jean Yawkey I come from Spain
and form a salon in particular so and we
are from abnormal steam it is - the
problem from Spain and our we
representing here attacks in all state
and it's a conversational game
it's a the core premise is that you can
control the character so he has his own
will and you you are just exciting you
are on the other side of this
conversation that between volume so
depending on the words you pick one
thing or other will happen are you doing
very careful with how they how these
dialogues and folks because he your visa
he is only real connection to do we know
I don't we don't know we don't have a
clue so we both need to work together to
find out what happened and how to get
out of that place so you need to build a
relationship between both of you so we
are measuring we are measuring the
emotional connection that we have we
start strangers and edge we need to move
closer and closer until I feel really
close friends and also we are measuring
his level of trust in you so he doesn't
charge you much you will encourage him
to do something and he will do just the
opposite because he doesn't rely on the
words
Duncan
[Music]
tonight
so the operation
[Music]
what's going on here
yeah interface
where we can actually see in the
connection and exporting
is our leverage infusion and we can
barely see
cyclist okay because
sure things work
so it doesn't know that we are able to
say you know it didn't we have also like
cinematics details
version systemically
this is related to that right
yeah we keep here now yeah
it's all trespassing
so again your interaction with this
person that he can't even see
this is the pendant with his husband oh
that's fine
is counting the
so if you for a second stage today
and our time away in Syria now shall we
applying their knowledge with the game
the only time you start counting
it feels really really desperate whistle
oh and you are down there and
so basically as the plane
[Music]
that interaction if he doesn't get that
baby's gonna go left
yeah it's like a social tamagochi but
there's functional needs instead of
fixing balls he needs just someone on
the other side to provide the authority
yes very unique I'll be the definitely
they forget that we had a lot of text
driven narrative on the policy choices
yes it can be one two or three different
choices
of course defend brunch is inviolable
and we have seven different endings
happen for us I mean love is the same
within what happened it was going to
happen is the same that they way we
approach is same as this one final
answer here we were formally colleague
that's great
and that's basically basically a
conversation that you had with a man out
here
my question is underneath this picture I
see detroit rana kamal sofia what
yes this if you click this panel on the
left
these things one of the inaugural would
and is based on the viewers of his
buddies and theory by typography
estimation Greek so he defined that for
define your health in your body you're
living a flood
black bile yellow bile into phlegm so
depending on the dialog these liquids
change its
happy emotional bonding
if some a specific princess he just went
through a French word is able to tell
his own name I was just about to say but
Uli's literally trying to count how much
interaction Janelle or just that's kind
of limited to certain events so in this
case we would not be able to not tell
Rico pregnancy
in some special things
buzzing OH
puzzle game where you can directly into
stuff because otherwise it would be
people to just find a larger intercooler
I squeeze half of the stuff so it buzzes
is the only way we're here actually
in fact the screen gotcha
we'll talk what it is in a release in
something we take a look at these
so as the game progresses this
quincannon sorry
the game we will destroy that is it
you need to figure out
and firstly if the user base is still
all because the game is polished yes
right and this is actually real about
everything
24:10 thorough job
[Music]
eight minutes
almost every chapter ends with a
tenderness or
because she's always gonna be short
anyway and
they replace me with the
[Music]
independence for hours
well we have like different endings -
so stem what are we looking at a release
he will be me to late April so we are
really close
initially we are going to release on
April 18th I think is going to be one
one or two week delayed because the Xbox
process is a little tougher but yeah
you'll be on Steam and Xbox really
really soon I saw you get a spots very
cool Jacare lovely to design tricep very
thank you thank you so much and happy
you like it thank you so much pleasure
thank you so much stereo sound super
unique
you